hey guys Pete here are you interested in
what's going on with the Game of Thrones
season 8 filming well we're gonna look
at what's going on right now what
happened last month news has been a
little bit slow coming out of there in
the beginning and there is some pretty
interesting stuff though so just in case
you missed it this is a spoilers video
if you don't want spoilers for season 8
that you're gonna want to stop watching
it now so most of what's going on with
the filming spoilers has to do with
Winterfell they've been shooting there
during the month of January and
yesterday I saw the first really good
photos of them filming of course they're
far away and you can't exactly tell
what's going on but it is pretty
exciting
there had been reports that there was a
lot of activity going on there film
crews spotlights a lot of security place
was pretty much locked down but Watchers
on the wall got some photographs from
Oakleaf photography who saw some shots
of the scenes in progress and another
one of their readers sent in a video
showing what it looked like in real time
so we had seen that they were doing a
lot of construction around the money
glass studios where they shoot the
Winterfell stuff it's in Northern
Ireland they have been reinforcing the
walls and doing things that it made it
look like there was gonna be a siege
there of course we expect that
Winterfell will not go untouched in this
war that's getting ready to code down in
season 8 but there was a lot of
questions on whether the White Walkers
would just roll in and destroy the place
or if there were more people that might
be taking a shot at Winterfell like
Cersei and the Lannister troops the
photos from Oakleaf actually showed that
there are people outside of the gate and
the video gives you an idea that they
may be using a battering ram because if
you listen to it you can hear that
they're sort of counting off almost or
they're working on something as a team
as they're out front of the gate there
from the distance that the photos were
taken from you can't tell a hundred
percent about anything that's going on
there we do know it's Winterfell they
are people not
white Walker looking beings there and if
you had to guess it could be Lannister
helmets that they're wearing it gives
you quite a bit to think about there
because if southern armies get to
Winterfell before the White Walkers how
will that all play out let's not forget
that Jamie had gone north at the end of
season seven and Cersei will likely be
pissed off about that and want to go
after but if you remember her plan was
to let them fight the White Walkers get
destroyed and then she could clean up
what was left over so it's a little bit
unclear how this would all go down when
it would be but most of what we've seen
so far has been in the early part of the
season based on the directors who were
in town
beyond that the cast has been doing a
lot of talking Maisie Williams in
particular has been doing a lot of
interviews because she has a new project
coming out that's unrelated so of course
people want to get in questions about
Game of Thrones when they talked to her
one quote that she had that's probably
not accurate but has caused the stir
with the fandom is that she said that
they were gonna wrap shooting in
December with the first episode coming
out in April she mentioned that you know
that's a really short turnaround for
such huge episodes there's so much that
goes into it but according to Watchers
on the wall they say that they have not
heard anything to contradict that the
filming will end in summer like we heard
last year so it doesn't seem like she
knew what she was talking about or
things have changed since she was
interviewed at that time Lena Headey
also did an interview and she said that
they did a big cast read-through of the
final season and everyone cried at one
point or another and in her opinion it
was just very surprising what happens
we've also heard from Peter Dinklage who
plays Tyrion he said that he thinks this
is the right time for the game of
Thrones series to end he feels like this
is the best possible way for it to
conclude
than dragging on and jumping the shark
we also found out that they will be
filming in Iceland again and I'm hoping
that they'll also be filming in Spain
which I mean hoping is not the right
word I hope they we see some good stuff
when they film in Spain but yeah the
there's a Icelandic new site that
reported that they will be filming there
in February that's dead of winter in
that part of the world so that is a lot
for speculation about what will be going
on there the white walkers are through
the wall so would they really be going
north of the wall again I mean we see a
lot of stuff from north of the wall in
Iceland but this could very well just be
other parts of the North's where the
white walkers will be marching we don't
know anything about it except for that
some of the main casts are expected to
take part in the shooting there which
pretty much every scene should have
members of the main cast at this point
since we're going to the end some other
stuffs that happened last month I wasn't
making videos last month so I didn't
report on any of this stuff yet we knew
that they were building a bunch of stuff
outside of Titanic studios and that they
were also filming in money glass which
is where Winterfell stuff gets filmed
but we also got some spoilers from
people who are close to the production I
mentioned that you know we we saw new
walls and battlements being built up and
we saw a lot of snow and different
things going on there's a trench or a
moat as well as the trebuchet but there
was this giant one that we saw outside
of Titanic studios and it does not seem
to be the same one all of it points to
Winterfell being under attack at least
once if not twice outside of Titanic
they were building for quite a while and
we weren't really sure what it was for
but it got pretty exciting because they
started doing fire tests and sources had
told Watchers on the wall that it was
the streets of King's Landing so that is
exciting because they're building
something that is gonna be King's
Landing that can
be destroyed that's why they're building
it outside of the studios instead of
using the Historic Places that they
generally use for King's Landing scenes
so this pretty much makes it sound like
the Narus will be bringing the dragons
to King's Landing or let's not forget
that the knight King also has a dragon
of his own at this point and the flames
that are gonna be burning this place
down could either be red or blue
depending on who actually hits King's
Landing first and the last big news of
interest was that over the holidays
everybody went home we found out that
Kit Harington
had come back to Belfast and then lo
siete Raynaud's in Spain reported that
Peter Dinklage had returned fans were
able to piece together that they were
shooting in the area where they shoot
the Winterfell [ __ ] scenes because the
director of photography
Fabian Wagner who's gonna be working
with Miguel sub pot snik for the third
and fifth episodes of season 8 posted a
nice shot of Shane's castle on Instagram
again sources say that at least the
first two episodes will visit the
Winterfell crypts in one scene that two
main characters are supposed to discuss
Ned's death that could certainly be John
and bran or anyone else for that matter
there's more to speculate here as well
because the Potts Nick is known for his
battle scenes we expect that he'll be
shooting a battle at Winterfell in
Episode three or five so could this mean
that the Crypt will be there whenever
the night King arrives so they will be
in the crypt at that point it's a lot to
think about there's a lot to the guests
on that one I mean the correct if
there's if they're shooting a bunch in
Winterfell the Crypt is just a good
place for a lot of things to happen
obviously Jon finding out his parentage
since Leanna's statues down there would
be expected I mean I expect that to
happen but we may see quite
bit more and I don't want to get too
excited about anything real cool
happening down there but if you've been
following the show and reading the books
for all this time you know there's
several different theories about things
that might be down there whether it may
be something left behind in her tomb the
one that I absolutely don't believe and
have never really been a big fan of
which is that there's a dragon under
Winterfell but we also have all of these
statues of the kings of winter and and
all the northern Kings from the
beginning of the stark household going
down deeper into the crypts there so
yeah it's an interesting place there's
not much in the way of leaked details to
actually give us an idea of what's gonna
happen there but I'm excited about it
either way because this is feeling like
we're gonna get some answers to
something and I can't wait we also know
that things were not going well for the
Nights Watch the last time we saw them
the night King had breached the wall and
passed through so there wasn't very many
of them in the first place and there
should be less at this point but there
is news that there have been Night Watch
extras doing start training and that
they will be shooting soon so maybe
we'll hear about that this week so
that's about it for now there is other
stuff that I will be touching on in the
coming weeks and we're gonna see new
stuff I plan to keep up with this like I
did last year when they were shooting
season 7 but we'll really have to see
how it goes it's a lot more exciting
whenever they have photos of the sets
but you know Northern Ireland is usually
pretty tight about that I mean you're
you got a lot of stuff that they're
shooting on and close sets in the
studios and all of that so you know
there's not really any chance of that
stuff getting out and then we might know
where they're at but we won't know what
they're doing so let me know in the
comments if you're excited about this
and what else are you excited about like
I said I will be keeping this up
hopefully that's the whole thing won't
get leaked again like last year and ruin
it but yeah I'm gonna be following along
and I won't be looking for the
leeks so I hope it doesn't get spoiled
completely the speculation is fun just
knowing what's gonna happen really ruins
the experience at least it did for me
last year so yeah make sure you
subscribe to my channel if you're not a
subscriber already be sure to turn on
notifications so that you will know as
soon as I upload a new video you can
follow me on my social media accounts
you can find the links for that on my
channel page you can come over and join
us on patreon and you can have input on
what goes on let me know what you want
to see videos about thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon